so just going to make a few introductory
points here I wanted to mention that we
are here in large part because the
doctor to be well and his lab we are
going to be talking about things related
to our knee seek but in the context of
those things that were pointing out by
him and his collaborators that are
important right now the presenters are
going to be dr. Adam Eric golonka he's
the chief scientist at the tower
bioinformatics research center and he's
going to be presenting together with
Julia panov she's a PhD student and both
of them will share both biological
interpretation or biological projects
and some technical things those work is
supported by the Taliban from Attucks
Research Center which is that University
of Haifa in Israel and also Pine biotech
when we are going to be talking about
some data examples based on data these
are published datasets we provide here
links to those published data sets
you're welcome to read the publication's
and also download data it's available
and also I want to point out that some
of these projects are prepared as
educational project project and are
available on our platform our platform
is the first of all the website that
you're on right now
edu dot t-- - bio info and you will find
there are also some courses on basics of
data analysis similar to what you're
going to be seeing here today so just an
overview of what we will cover today or
hope to cover first of all it's going to
be about next-generation sequencing data
pre-processing including trimming
technical sequences and PCR duplicates
and the second point about processing of
next-generation sequencing is going to
be around quantification of expression
levels conventional pipelines and also
identification
eisah forms we will touch on the
challenge of gene set enrichment
analysis so annotation of genes but also
gene set enrichment and finally we will
practice practice and utilize some
machine learning methods including
unsupervised analysis of expression data
and supervisor now so now I'm going to
hand over the presentation to Julia and
Julia will share with you her
presentation about biological examples
ok should be able to share your screen
now ok hi can you see my screen
can you see my screen yes okay great so
hi everyone Azealia mentioned my name is
Julia and I used the platform in my
research for a neurodevelopmental
disorders and I also collaborate and
assist other groups in using the
platform in their research in areas such
as marine biology evolutionary biology
and cancer studies but I'm actually on
the wrong slide right
yeah you want me to show your slacks
okay Julia I have your slides here if
you want to I'm trying to get this
working I'm sorry for some hopefully
sorry so okay so my goal today before we
begin the hands-on part of the workshop
is to give you a taste of what we can do
with the top robotics platform and also
with bioinformatics in general so I will
focus on one project that we have been
working on and I will briefly tell you
about the kind of data and the analysis
we used to generate the results that I
will present afterwards every step of
the analysis that you will be hearing
about was done on the platform so let me
begin yeah I'm on the wrong slide I'm
not in the present mode
wait
oh yeah yes sorry about this but my
sharing screen is not working for me
could you do it for me and share my and
share the presentation for me and I will
just speak okay can you hear or can you
see my screen yeah okay great so and so
maybe you can show the next slide so I
will focus on one project about cell
lines and I will tell you about the kind
of data and the analysis that we use to
generate the results that I present
afterwards and so let me begin the
project we will be looking at is based
on the analysis by the gray group and I
hope you had a chance to to look at the
publication but if you didn't it's okay
we will be I will go as well so the 70
cell lines of breast cancer and we used
only 49 of these cell lines that had all
the molecular profiles for them and as
you can see on the slide we had gene
expression data and RNA editing data so
the RNA seek data is actually produced
by sequencing the RNA molecules in the
sample so from this RNA sequencing we
can get two kinds of data we can get the
gene expression data that we will go
into more detail and you will have a
chance yourself to practice how to do it
exactly and also we can do RNA editing
and we could generate the RNA editing
table from those data as well so what it
what edit those are might've forgotten
or don't know is a post-transcriptional
modification of
primary RNA molecules as you can see on
the slide
sometimes RNA molecules are by a special
enzyme and there are different types of
editing there is a substitution of
cytosine to uracil that in the
sequencing data we see as a timing and
another type of modification could be a
substitution of adenine to by go online
so we studied these two modifications
together with gene expression and RNA
editing events can have very big effects
on afterwards untranslated protein and
the protein can be unfunctional or it
can lose the biting sites for micro
rna's that it had in wild-type state and
the exact mechanism and the function of
editing events are not completely
understood but it has been shown that
RNA editing plays significant role in
different types this is about the kind
of data we were looking at gene
expression and RNA editing and question
is why why would someone might be
interested in data driven analysis that
actually has no planning beforehand we
were not looking at specific genes or
perturb rated States we were just
looking at the data overall so we were
interested actually in trying to
identifies subtypes of breast cancer as
you know breast cancer is a
heterogeneous disease and our
understanding of its complexity is still
evolving so on this slide you can see
kind of our history of what it was
how people have with time have been
trying to identify the subtypes of
cancer breast disease and recently
people are trying to identify subtypes
of cancer based on what we call
multi-omics analysis by different layers
RNA data DNA data data all together
one analysis to find specific unique
characteristic Euler characteristics of
subtypes of cancer and as you probably
know one of the methods or model cancer
our cell lines and these cell lines are
subtypes of cancer or or types of cancer
and they are well established cell lines
originally taken from patients that
underwent biopsies and they are very
useful models for studying the cancer as
you can see on the next slide we can
have profiles of different types of cell
lines with genomic profile and as well
as pharmacological profile and based on
these profiles we can better find
treatments for patients that have
similar genomic profile so of course
cell lines are not are not the best
models of cancer they lack some of the
important things that cancer and
patients have and that is hydrogen media
inside the tumor cells and also the
stromal component and however despite
the limitations cell lines continue to
be very important research models and
preclinical trial tools in cancer
biology so understanding the
characteristics of different cell lines
can help us better understand both the
subtypes of cancer
and also sometimes understand that some
cancer line is not a good model for the
forecast for the type of cancer that it
was used for as a motto
so in our on the next slide you will see
that our our project was based on 49
such cell lines we had gene expression
table and you can see on the slide the
gene expression table is actually a
collection of all genes in stem we have
different samples with different
profiles for each gene
so expression and on the bottom table
RNA editing table you see chromosome
regions of the genome that have RNA
editing events with high probability and
what we're trying to do on the next
slide you will see that to take these
two tables and find groups of genes that
are and groups of RNA editing that
together have the similar sample
profiles so you can see on the slide
that for example we could find a group
of genes in yellow and a group of RNA
editing events also in yellow and they
would give us clustering of samples that
are very similar to each other you can
see the purple arrows pointing to the
clustering of the samples and and those
genes and RNA editing events would be
somehow linked or another case could be
that the genes in green and RNA editing
events in green that could also give us
a separation of samples a different
separate example or for example an
outlier sample that is somehow unique in
its molecular characteristics and
so the goal of our analysis in this in
in this part in this project was exactly
that to find these somehow different
samples that are different in molecular
characteristics from all others and so
this is actually what we were able to do
was to identify one unique cell line and
that was very different from all others
on the next slide you will see matrixes
of distances between samples so this is
those are distances between samples and
you can see in blue there are lines in
blue on both tables one table is
distances of samples based on the gene
expression table and on the other table
take on the other side is the matrix of
distances between samples based on the
RNA editing events and you can see that
both of these tables actually separate
only one cell line HCC 202 you can see
that separation in blue the distances
between HCC 202 and all other cell cell
lines are very high and they are painted
in blue for visual representation so
another way of showing this is going to
be on the next slide is to look at the
pca over the actual if you took took now
these genes and you would look at the
pca based on the expression level of
these genes you would see that these
genes that we chose are only present in
this sample and also with RNA editing
events they are also only present in
this signal so without actually
designing our experiments so that we
could target specific genes we were
still able to choose a group of genes
and a group of RNA editing events that
clearly separates this sample from all
others so let's look a little bit at
kind of genes these are on one side we
found olfactory receptors and micro
rna's those were the expression levels
and on the other side we found rabjeet a
basis
so can we from knowing these genes can
we now say anything about this cell line
how is it different from all others well
we could have some hypothesis and
afterwards we could maybe generate more
experiments or take more data to
validate our hypothesis one of the
hypotheses we were thinking of is that
micro RNAs are known to bind to genes
and to prevent the expression of these
genes micro RNAs are also known to bind
to a RAB gtp aces which are very
important transport molecules and when
Rob gypped a gtpases are edited
sometimes these binding sites are
missing and no more no longer micro RNAs
can be buying it can bind to this to
these genes because of that we would
have a very high expression of tranport
not like us trap databases and it's
known in the cancer studies that all
factory receptors can cause malignancy
in cancer or aggressiveness in cancer so
wrap gtp aces by trafficking the
olfactory receptors to nearby cells can
actually make the cancer cell line or
the cancer tumor much more aggressive so
this would be some kind of hypothesis
that could be validated more with more
targeted with more targeted experiments
later on so
this was a brief glimpse at what can be
done with data driven by informatics
approach and we hope that now you have a
little bit of a more understanding of
why this approach can be helpful in
biological studies and life scientists
life sciences and now I hope you will
enjoy the work the hands-on workshop so
thank you very much for your attention
okay Julia and now I'm going to switch
it over to Vladimir as it was said
before glad in there is the chief
scientist at the table bioinformatics
research center he as working
development of the platform and
extending it for both research and
education
[Music]
a microphone isn't a zoo okay okay so
hope that the screen is shared correctly
if there are any problem please let me
know and before we start please let us
check that all of you have an access to
your accounts at the tab whereby in the
platform and that you have all the files
in the archive prepared for this
workshop so please let us know if anyone
does not have this files as we'll use
them later on in our practice so in any
case we begin with some theory and then
we'll proceed to practical analysis
hopefully the theory will be relatively
short and it will be related to the
basis of RNA sequencing pipeline
I mean library preparation that we need
the step that we need to understand in
order to understand what are the main
steps of the analysis as you know
perfectly well everything starts with
the genome which part codes proteins so
genes code for proteins but proteins are
not generated just directly from genome
there's an intermediate step genes give
rise to transcripts to my to messenger
rna's and these messenger RNAs are then
translated to proteins and all the
cell's for the fixed organized for
example all the cell's for one human
well generally if we avoid thinking
about cancer cells for a while generally
have the same genes but these genes have
different activity
different levels of activity different
expression levels in different cells in
different tissues so some genes may be
present in the genome but give rise to
no messenger RNA is no transcripts and
hence no proteins some can give rise to
an essential amount of transcripts and
essential thus essential amount of
proteins and roughly speaking sequencing
sequencing process can be described as
follows we have all these transcripts
these transcripts are randomly divided
into small pieces and this pieces are
read by sequencing machine so read
letter by letter nucleotide by
nucleotide the problem is that we do not
know the origin for all these pieces who
get after this reading but anyway we
know the sequence for human genome we
know the nucleotide sequences for all
the genes so we can map our shout
segments on transcripts or better to say
probably better to say on genes and if
there are no reads mapped on a gene for
example gene bet shean be we see that
this gene has zero or at least low
expression level more reads more short
segments we have the higher the
expression level is but if we go deeper
in the details we'll see that this
process has several intermediate steps
these steps might be slightly different
between technologies but generally these
steps are the following first all the
transcripts are shattered into sub
pieces so we have shattering and in fact
we have one copy of each segment more
copies of the transcript of a transcript
we have more pieces related to this gene
we're
served in our sample of the chattering
at the next step
adapters are negated to these small
pieces in fact these prayer reads in
fact this Legation is successful not for
all small pieces but at least these
adapters are gated to a sufficient part
of this short reads them PCR
amplification is performed that is
multiple copies of each read with legate
adapters is generated for example if
there are six round of PCR amplification
well if there are two rounds of PCR
amplification we get to multiple by two
four copies for each piece if we have
six rounds of PCR amplification we get
to power 6 so 64 copies more rounds we
have we get more copies for each segment
there is a slight problem related to the
fact that this higher efficiency is
different for different segments so for
some pieces we have more copies for some
pieces we have lower numbers of copies
so we're speaking about average numbers
of copies web gain at this step so
please pay attention to the fact that
indeed there are multiple copies of each
segment after this step but sequencing
takes not all the pieces but takes only
a relatively small fraction of these
pieces and reads these small fraction if
the number of copies is relatively low
it's the case when the initial number
the initial amount of RNA is sufficient
and the quality of library preparation
is also sufficient then generally will
read only
one copy for each short segment number
of duplicates so number of reads
originated from the same small piece of
initial transcript will be well above
well below 10% if we start with lower
amount of RNA if so we need to perform
more steps more cycles of PCR
amplification we get more copies for
each segment and the number of these VCR
duplicates increases more over the
absence of uniformity and the number of
copies starts to play the role but after
that we can continue to our previous
discussion we simply map all these reads
on initial genes and estimated an
expression level just counting reads
mapped on each gene so this logic this
logic explains us this logic explain us
the major steps of the analysis we may
start with pre-processing so if there
are additional segments negated
additional sequences negated to our
initial segments adapters this adapters
may be removed prior to the analysis
additionally there's a standard effect
of low quality amps for reads they also
can be trimmed to increase mapping
quality then PCR duplicates so identical
reads that are potentially the corpus of
the same initial segment can be removed
from the analysis this steps increase
the quality of the resultant mapping so
we map reads on known genes unknown
transcripts but at this stage there are
different strategy different strategies
we may focus just on estimation on
expression level of known genes in this
case we map all this reads to the set of
non genes known transcripts known
isoforms we can also want to try to
identify novel transcripts novel
isoforms of known genes or completely
novel transcripts it's a more rare type
of the analysis but it's also not
technically hard and definitely there's
a combined strategy after the reads are
mapped we can proceed to the
quantification of expression level still
just in order to understand how it can
be performed
technically without going deep into the
details of mapping algorithms of the
estimation algorithms let us get started
with the use of the terrible Barre info
platform let us prepare the pipeline
that performs all these jobs we've
discussed we won't run this pipeline as
the size of sequencing data is generally
relatively large so processing time is
also relatively large it may take hours
or even several days if we have many
samples so we'll just prepare these
pipeline in order to do it we proceed to
the platform please let us know if there
are any problem with it and we go to the
analysis related to RNA sequencing data
so here it is so yes there's
introduction so what we can choose here
what are the options today who are
dealing with human genome so we select
the set of genes of the genome as you
see so we select Homo sapiens there are
two types of reads single end and pair
and for example for our today discussion
we have some parent data and we need to
okay I think I see it from here
great thank you so let's just try okay
and the size of the size of sequencing
data is large so uploading of new files
can also be slow we use just links to
the files that are already inside the
system to have this short test so plug
in here somebody was just asking if I
think just to make sure so he'll is
everybody on the same page can we move
forward or okay if you go back one slide
okay currently I'm just change screen so
if again we are inside the platform so
when we log in we can press on the areas
of the analysis link and then we've got
sections for analysis of various types
of omics data and for various
pre-processing here we go to the
analysis of RNA sequencing data so
here's the link on the top
left-top link so here we're here in
order to perform the analysis we to
perform standard analysis we use type of
sequencing data we have single end
sequencing or parent sequencing well
currently in many cases its parent PE
parent and select genome or the set of
genes select transcriptome we're working
is so parent and Homo sapiens and then
we upload files so we press on upload
files and add groups button please let
me know if there are any problem with
what's going on and for our case for the
case when we use files that are already
inside we use URL bulk upload here it is
so here we go to the files in the
archive you have main files and for
example if you want to start with just
two samples we use the file links two
samples dot spld this is a very small
file which contains only links to our
data but not the data itself
okay so dick leagues if you do not have
these files please let us know and we'll
simply fix this problem there was a
question so what are the four drop-down
options so okay okay so first we can
deal with different types of
experimental data
I mean model organisms organism for each
genome and transcriptome is known so and
we have everything known for an organism
our human sapiens so is the first option
data type we're dealing is so typically
for RNA sequencing we start with first
few files if we begin from the very
beginning then the type of reads single
and or pair and and if we're dealing
with model organisms we just select
genomic and transcriptomic data for
related to this organism so organism and
rich type so then okay okay then we
upload a file from our set okay just to
clarify about our set what what we mean
is there is a button to download files
on the page that you're on so you should
have downloaded the zip file and that
zip file contains multiple folders one
of the folders is called main files web
will mainly deal with main files so you
download the file you unzip the file
inside you see the folder
called main files and then we will be
using the files that have an extension
dot svl so okay and we select this file
hopefully we'll get used to it promptly
as we'll create a number of pipeline
today of pipelines today the file is
links to samples and then we go further
with our analysis here we're not going
to make differential expression analysis
or any complicated analysis currently
were focused on just estimation of
expression level so after pressing
define groups we simply say that we need
no groups no additional information for
this analysis so cancel no groups and
then we start creating our pipeline so
the pipeline should be started so again
I select start then a possible option is
okay here again so let me just show it
once again here we use bulk uploads as
we're uploading only links to files but
not the files themselves so later on
we'll use main uploading button add
files but currently were using bulk
upload button and upload the file links
to samples dot svl so we then press on
define groups and say that we have no
groups and go on so okay let's take a
look whether they're right and a problem
at this stage if not we'll try to go
further
okay okay so we initialize our pipeline
with the start module start and okay
then for trimming adapters and
low-quality ends of reads we can for
example use trim emetic module we press
on the module and then confirm by
pressing save PCR duplicate removal can
be performed where the module PCR clean
so default option default technical
option is perfectly okay mapping can be
performed if we're going to map all our
reads on jeans on transcriptome for
example with bowtie or bwh for example
with bowtie and expression level
quantification can be performed there
are some expression table module here we
need to choose the units for expression
level quantification we'll discuss this
units in a minute or two so for example
fragments per kilobytes per million map
reads it became will also do and that's
all that's all so this model will give
us quantifications for expression levels
here we can just finish our pipeline and
model and save give a name to this
pipeline for example test pipeline or
whatever you like and then in order to
run pipeline we won't do it now as this
pipeline takes
okay okay so now we won't run this by
plan we just looked at how this pipeline
can be created so while we're trying to
solve our problem let me just repeat all
these steps some people are saying that
they are still doing making the pipeline
so yeah please let me know when
everything is okay I'll just repeat all
the steps for people for going on just
to make visual what we're doing so I
just recreate this pipeline I start with
the areas of the analysis RNA sequencing
select parent sequencing
select genome upload our file links to
samples tell that I need no groups for
the analysis then start for example
dream adapters if I select a model which
is not required
I selected traumatic but I want to
remove it from the pipeline I can press
just right mouse button and remove it so
removing is performed with the right
mouse button but I add traumatic I add
PCR cleaning I use mapping this time for
example bowtie I after mapping I need to
go from reads from mapped reads from
read positions to expression level
quantification which is before and by or
same expression table and that's all and
that is all and pipeline name
and in order to start this pipeline I
need to press run pipeline but currently
I won't do it okay so is everything okay
with this simple test we'll okay okay so
anyway it's just an example and as you
see we can easily include different
types of models for each step in our
analysis for example we want we can I'm
just going on with my order because is
not essential things I just gives
several comments for people or already
who have already created these pipeline
so there are different moods for example
adding sequence adding mapping on genome
and cufflinks calf merge models will
also allow us to add steps related to
the identification of neural isoforms so
algorithmically it's not so simple but
as we have all these modules all these
algorithms inside the platform the usage
is really simple we add additional
modules to the pipeline and wait for the
result more modules more execution time
but definitely it's not a problem for
the majority of experiments when the
data is collected for weeks months and
sometimes even for years
so additional data to of the analysis is
sometimes not essential but from the
other hand faster analysis
is definitely what who also wants to
help blue diamond yeah there are some
questions that Sahil wants to ask on
behalf of some people
[Music]
ok so what I understood the question is
what do these buttons actually do to
explain a little bit more in detail what
traumatic and DCR clean you do so that
it's clear to everyone it's not just
buttons on the screen ok so thank you
very much for your question and let us
return to our standard scheme of the
analysis of RNA sequencing which just
followed our general idea of the
experimental of the preparation of
experimental data so first in we located
the adapters to our short sequences and
standard pipeline may may wants to
remove these short sequences this is
performed by the first model we added
traumatic so traumatic loops at the ends
of reads tries to identify these
standard adapters and has this model
also has functionality to try to
identify normal adapters which are not
in its database
forms just trimming so remove these
adapters from the reeds
we have sequenced then we discussed
these are duplicates we discussed PCR
duplicates and so our next step was to
remove these PCR duplicates and this is
what is done by the is our clean
algorithm so it just looks for pairs
triples quadruples and so on of
identical reads and leaves only one copy
so the forms these bizarre duplicate
removal the next step is mapping these
short reads on genes so for each gene
and for each short segment we want to
find out whether this read has a good
position above these gene so and after
this stage we've got positions on the
transcription set for each read several
some reads can have now allowed
positions and for some reads we may fail
to understand to identify its origin
several some reads can be mapped on
different locations but all this
information is obtained by the mapping
model for example as we are making on
the transcriptomic data bowtie bwa
sounds like that and the final step is
going from read counts to to go from
this mapping to the identification of
expression levels to the quantification
of expression levels and it's performed
by them and it's performed by the our
same expression table
modules so definitely algorithms that
light behind these titles are not very
simple especially if we're speaking
about mapping and quantification but the
purpose of these models is just as I
described so let us please now have a
very short pause I suppose for three or
four minutes just a short technical
break and after this break we'll try to
discuss what are the standard units of
quantification why we should go from raw
read counts to some more complex
measures so currently just for a moment
just for several me okay can everyone
hear me okay during this break it would
be helpful I assumed that everybody had
a chance to take a look at the first
pipeline that we created let me turn on
my video here okay okay so while we're
taking this short little break I'm going
to turn on the microphone for Co and and
please the heel if you want to just make
sure that anyone has questions
[Music]
sorry I could not hear that cou yeah so
we you know you have the quality of
weeds and I think we can touch on that
subject but in the meantime what I want
to do in this short break is just maybe
collect all of the questions and so we
will be able to answer them one by one
so we noted it down the question number
one is quality of raw fast Q files
before you start the mapping
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
by using this pipeline okay about the
eyes it forms just a quick note we will
get to that great question I think as
Louie has shown with in the beginning we
had a method to combine multiple sources
with Muhammad's data identify
relationships between he knows I think
we will get to that form again another
question
of minutes artistic apps so the basis of
the connections like I have person it
means to have these happen that app
whether I will be okay so what is that I
what is the logic behind selecting
specific steps okay so there are
different methods that the form of the
task generally I hope that we discussed
the logic of the preparation of the
experimental data and so here here each
step of the analysis simply follows the
experimental step just in two or three
minutes I'll tell you that in reality
several steps can be emitted for example
pre-processing can be emitted but
generally this pipeline just use back
from reads we have out of the sequencing
machine to initial data we edit adapters
has remove them we potentially edit be
shared duplicates had hands we remove
them and in fact go back to the initial
set of short sequencing sequences this
reads originated from original
transcripts then we try to map all these
short sequences on genes in order to
understand which gene which genes are
associated with many segments these
genes are the genes with high expression
level which genes have no almost no
short segments associated with this gene
so these genes are genes with low
expression so unfortunately if we now go
my
deeper into the details will fail to
complete even a short overview because
indeed this app reasons have been
studies designed for I think more than
at least fifteen years and there are
great algorithmic ideas behind this
algorithm but currently we're focus just
on overview these steps okay questions
yes and just maybe you can quickly help
address those so the question number one
was how to know quality of raw fast
queue files before the mapping question
number two was about the logic of
different steps of analysis question
number three was about making
correlations between multiple omics data
question number four was about
identification of isoforms so I know you
probably don't want to address
everything at the same time but maybe
you can just give an overview of when
those questions okay so starting from
the beginning we can use we can still
use pre-processing steps and look at the
output statistics of what what we're
doing with these models provide us a
statistics for example with the ratio of
P shard of reads identified as PCR
duplicates and has the reads which have
removed we see the number of reads for
which adapters has been have been
treated but anyway we can there are ways
currently not implemented as modules as
we use them really to look just at mean
base quality reported by the sequencing
machine so fast queue files along with a
nucleotide for each position
contains an estimate of equality for
this position and just look at a number
of positions with high quality and low
quality to the number of breeds
containing only high quality basis it's
possible but another possibility is to
get statistics after the mapping for
example to get number of reads or
percentage of reads successfully mapped
on genes to get ratio to get proportion
of reads that had a unique location with
respect to genes and to make a
conclusion about the quality of this
fescue file based on these overall
statistics so prime primarily number of
PCR duplicates that were removed number
of reads that were not mapped that were
mapped uniquely and that were mapped
simultaneously and on different
locations so this is a short well not
complete answer to the first question
so going further about well for example
identification of novel isoforms when we
try to identify novel isoforms we are
looking at reads mapping them not on
transcriptome but on genome or better to
say on exotic segments of the genome and
these reads can link one exam to another
exam so reads can start inside one exam
and have there are the end of this read
in the Artic it's on so this read just
generates a link between these exams and
we have a map of all possible links so
of all exon exon links supported by
reads having this map we can try to
identify genes
so combinations of exams corresponding
to a fix gene or we can find reads well
logically let me avoid explaining here
the details well fairly well mapped on a
part of a genome that is not currently
identified identified as known coding
region so it's the logic behind
identification of novel isoform so i
think these are just short answers to
two of the four questions
well let me avoid discussing links
between multiple omics types today as
it's really along
topic so Julia just mentioned that there
are some in-house tools we have for
these analysis for example the
Association there are some publicly
available tools for example for
multi-omics clustering these tools are
also collected certain tools are also
collected and the platform so there are
multi-omics analysis sections well it's
these are just some possibilities some
are tommix clustering some associations
and a number of additional models but
it's just a topic for another discussion
unfortunately I'm afraid it will take
long even to make an introduction here
and there was the fourth question so
could you please remind it
okay if there are more questions I can
also maybe say that we will have a
number of breaks further on and it would
be probably helpful if we can move on
with the material so that we can do some
practical aspects of building the
pipelines and understanding their logic
and as we get to the next stage we can
take some more questions there okay fine
so apparently first I want to say that
there are at least there are two main
types of bizarre duplicates artificial
posad replicates which originate from
these step of library preparation PCR
amplification but there may also be
natural TCR duplicates so while
performing these pre-processing step
removing of these are duplicates you
definitely should keep in mind the
details of your experiments primarily
well as one of the major parameters the
amount of RNA material you started with
enhance the number of the share
implication cycles you performed and if
you're especially if you are dealing
potentially with short sequences for
example not genes but you have focused
on micro rna's then these beasts are the
shared applicant removal step should be
used with caution or even completely
devoted there are some sources so here
you may find links that state that these
pre-processing steps mister duplicate
removal adapter removal well generally
improve the quality of the final
expression level quantification
this improvement is moderate so
pre-processing can be even avoided with
getting good results
so let us currently try to discuss what
can what measures for expression level
quantification can be used and the first
measure we already discussed is very
simple it is number of reads mapped on
these gene first we can work with just
raw counts the total number of reads
mapped on a gene a slight problem here
is that several that some reads in many
cases amount of reads are mapped
simultaneously on different locations so
we may want to split this one count
count associated with one read between
all the locations to which this read has
been mapped the simplest way is to split
this one count
uniformly but in many cases more complex
statistical models can be used and for
example these are same module we added
to the pipeline uses a relatively
complex bias and approach so the idea is
that we can perform this splitting of
counts associated with the same read in
a more sensible way but in any way if
we're dealing with counts either raw or
so processed so called expected counts
after this splitting
what we have we may have two genes and
for one gene will have many reads mapped
of this gene and for another gene we may
have much lower
of reads mapped on this gene can we say
that well natural expression level of
the first gene is for example expression
level measured in the number of mRNA
molecules associated with a gene can we
say that for for the first gene this
expression level is higher as we have
higher number of reads unfortunately no
and the reason is very simple if read if
gene is longer so then shattering this
gene or mRNA molecular associated in two
parts will simply give us more pieces so
longer mRNAs give more pieces in
comparison with short messenger rna's
but the number of molecules we have is
the same so in order to get while
meaningful quantification we should keep
in mind the length of a gene and we may
perform norman with respect to this
length of gene another idea behind
scaling behind norman is the following
imagine that we have one sample we
sequence this sample and with them
repeat sequencing just the same sample
with adding one additional cycle with
adding just depth of sequencing i mean
reading generating twice as much reads
so generally will have two fold increase
in the number of reads mapped to each
genes simply as we have more reads into
consideration more genes in our
collection but it's just the same sample
and it's natural to have the same
estimations of expression levels that is
why we should also keep in mind sequence
in depth for example measured in the
number of reads mapped on transcripts
and that's why we use another scaling
item total number of mapped reads and
it's just a very standard unit for
expression level quantification
fragments per kilo base per million
mapped reads so the number of reads is
scaled by gene or transcript length and
by the total number of reads we have
another usual unit for expression level
quantification is TPM transcripts per
million
CPM units right for fixed sample only
for fixed sample all right simply
proportional to F pkms but the
coefficient of the coefficient see here
the coefficient of proportionality is
selected in such a way that the sum of
all TPS for a given sample is exactly is
exactly 1 million so let us try to
briefly discuss the logic which stands
behind this unit to p.m. as unlike fpkm
CPM have a very national biological
interpretation so let us consider the
following amount number of reads mapped
on one gene multipled by the mean read
length and divided by gene length so let
us try to discuss what is the sense
behind these formula number of reads
mapped on one gene multiple by meme read
length so what we have in the
denominator here so what we have here
number of reads multiple by mean read
length is in fact the number of
sequenced nucleotides associated with
this gene so number of nucleotides
associated with this gene we have after
sequencing after the division after
dividing this product by gene length
we instead get number of molecules
number of messenger RNA is associated
with this gene or with this either form
that we sequenced if we sum these
quantities over all genes we have in
fact we simply get the total number of
molecules of messenger RNA of the
sequencing and if we take this amount
this amount for one gene and then
divided by the total amount we have a
fraction of messenger rna's of
transcripts associated with the gene of
interest in the health eternity of
sequenced molecules so it's just a
fraction multiplication by 1 million
gives us scaling so CPM tells us the
following in each million of messenger
rna's in the sample CPM is the amount of
molecules associated with the genes who
are looking at so for example if CPM is
10 then out of each million molecules
approximately 10 are molecules
associated with these gene and another
question related to quantification of
expression levels is scaled all these
quantities read counts fpkm TPM are the
quantities measured in so called
linear scale so original scale for the
majority for the for many types of the
analysis this amounts this linear scale
amounts are lot scaled so we take
logarithm the reason there are multiple
reasons for these transformation for
example one of the main reasons is
related to the statistics as for the
majority of genes the distribution of
expression level is law
normal so after taking logarithm we get
normal distribution which is very good
for the analysis in terms of classical
probability theory and mathematical
statistics another reason is that linear
scale is simply similar for dealing with
for biology relative differences in
expression level are more meaningful
than absolute differences if we say that
the difference between expression levels
is 100 TPMS it will say almost nothing
but if we say that the expression level
increased twofold threefold tenfold it
gives more information and log scaling
simply moves these relative differences
to differences that can be obtained by
taking standard arithmetic means and
differences so for example in log scale
two-fold difference is simply a
difference by 1 lakh to unit difference
equal to 3 lakh fold units is equivalent
to the difference to the 8 fold
difference in the initial scale the
problem with going to the innate to the
logarithm scale very well not essential
problem frankly speaking is that
logarithm is defined only for numbers
greater than 0 and for many genes the
expression level is just 0 so we can
take logarithm we get minus infinity
that's why a small shift is introduced
the alias of shift fry and one of the
standard one of the standard values is
simply 1 1 of possible values but it's
not the only option in any case this
shift the differences in this
shift effect only genes with low
expression level and we should also we
should keep in mind that low expressed
genes that for low expressed genes
quantification just experimentally is an
exact so we can't be sure that
expression level of low expressed gene
is measured is measured really precisely
that is why genes with low expression
level in many cases are simply removed
from the analysis but log scaling is
also a standard step of the analysis so
running the pipeline we have just
writing the pipeline we discussed simply
gives us estimates of expression levels
in the units we set for the samples we
upload it to the platform in order to
see results and in order to compare the
results for different types of
pre-processing including or not
including PCR duplicates removal
including or not including trimming
adapters you may look now won't do it
add the files you have in the subfolder
output files there's the next level
subfolder earrin a sequence in
comparison with an excel file so for two
samples here you have just F pkms linear
scale it becames for these two samples
just without any processing without with
pre-processing that includes only
adaptive streaming and low quality and
streaming and with the prep recession we
discussed so shortly
if we compare results for the case is no
pre-processing versus no duplicates
removal or even for the other case you
see that for the majority of genes gene
expression estimates are roughly the
same so for example for these genes
along the x-axis we have expression
level quantification obtained by one
type of pre-processing and y-axis gives
expression level estimate for the other
type of pre-processing so for the
majority of genes we get the same or
approximately the same results but there
are some transcripts for which the
difference is really high it seems for
example that the point that the dot I'm
pointing at is not very far from the
line x equals y but the difference is
more than one and this difference of
more than one is a two-fold difference
as we're dealing with log to scale so
mass data experiment gives us the
general view but for the individual
genes for the individual players we have
we need additional verification we need
additional validation if we want to deal
further with some small subset of genes
of isoforms identified at this mass
experiment so in any case this analysis
simply gives us huge tables so it gives
us dozens of thousands of numbers for
each sample if we perform mapping on
only unknown transcripts we have these
numbers only for known ones if we add if
we add models for the identification of
potential novel transcripts that
definitely need additional
what level validation then we have
estimates as you hear transcripts marked
with X log beginning these numbers
additionally for potential novel
transcripts but the question is what we
can do further with this amount of data
these expression level tables are not
the end of the story
they are just the beginning of the story
and so now we'll just start discussing
what we can do with these data so let us
make a decision do we need a break here
or yeah please look for that knowledge
now in a bathroom or a brief question
straight
okay oh okay
okay so currently we'll just try to see
what we can do with the table with these
tables we'll use real tables for the
cell line experimental data Julia
briefly described out of these dozens of
thousands of genes we removed okay okay
so break shut break okay well I just
noticed that the microphone actually
doesn't work that great when you take it
far away is it I know it's fine but I
think the farther you go from the
computer
[Music]
okay so let us know when we should start
again there was a request from the
audience to see the speaker on video
especially when there are questions so
we are answering to those requests
okay so it's a heel back there okay so
don't start again please continue okay
okay so currently we'll try to see what
we can do with these expression tables
and we start with a very simple analysis
so we have several about 50 cell lines
all cell lions originated from patients
with breast cancer and it's probable
that all these lines are similar to each
other as we're dealing with sea lions
associated with just the same pathology
but how can we know if it's true or not
it's really impossible to go through all
these numbers just by eyes and our
visualization stops as an dimension
equal to two or three so if we have two
attributes we can visualize our data as
dots in a plane three attributes can
provide us Association of samples with
dots in a 3d space but we have thousands
of genes thousands tens of thousands of
genes and so this visualization is looks
impossible however we can try to find an
optimum
plane that keeps as much data as
possible and still allows us provides us
an opportunity of visual inspection of
the data so currently I'll try to
explain what I mean using a very simple
example and then we'll return to the
presentation so we have a simple Pam so
in fact what you see in your screen what
you see in your screen is a 2d
projection of a 3d object if we choose a
plane of projection in a poor way we
have very poor understanding of an
object we're dealing with so we have
just the same object what we can cannot
understand what we're dealing with in
this projection change in the plane
changing the projection gives us better
and better way of seeing these objects
for example in this projection you can
really understand what is the edge what
is the object okay okay so if there are
any problem with video please let us
know I think it is working it's working
okay
great so and a very simple thing can be
applied to the data we're dealing with
we can try to find optimal plane or
optimal 3d space or optimal planes that
can this help us in visualization of the
data of the data we have so let us try
to test the thing I'm talking about so
let us create and run our pipeline and
expect inspect the result so we'll be
working with unsupervised analysis as in
these analysis we know nothing
about data underlying our samples we
think we start at least with the
understanding that all samples are
similar they originated from the same
pathology so in order to perform this
simple kind of the analysis we select
unsupervised analysis section upload
expression table for the analysis this
is the file cell line expression data
dot txt we'll take a look inside this
file in a minute or two so we select
cell lines
expression data file okay so main files
in the folder we are working with today
and the file cell lines expression data
healthy great we select this file cell
lines expression data txt and press open
button so this file is uploaded to the
system unlike the previous analysis here
we indeed take the file from your
computer's to the system so it may take
several seconds please let us know in
case of any problem so again we add
files file cell lines expression data
so that's it and go on continue continue
start then our principle component
analysis module is PC draw as we want to
have plots as an output PC draw the
default options here are okay in order
to get additional help regarding these
options if you need to if you need
explanation you can just point on I
zooms and have short comments but here
we say that one visualization associated
with three first principal components we
need no scaling centering and transpose
explains which type which information
gives the arrows and we wish their
columns samples and genes or issac
formers expression so he were then it's
just the end of our pipeline and
pipeline name see draw for example say
the name is the name L then after the
name is saved simply run this pipeline
by pressing run pipeline button that's
it
each other pipeline is starting it may
take several seconds once the pipeline
is started even monitor its progress
here are in my pipelines pipelines
reports the results and everything for
all pipelines you previously had so
again pressing on the name brings us to
the screen with the pipeline progress
while the pipeline runs let us take a
look at the file we uploaded in order to
understand what we have inside our
system what is this file it is a very
simple file in which for each sample
each cell line and for each jeans out of
well about 7,000 jeans we have
expression here expression is measured
in log scale log two scales fpkm so we
use F became units with log two scaling
and so initially each cell line is a
point in a space with a number of
dimensions close to 7,000 well I reload
it's to see their progress so for me
almost completed and in order to
understand the simple picture we project
all these data we project all this data
simply to a 2d plane if you low the page
you'll see the progress it won't take
too long but it may require
several dozens of seconds or a couple of
minutes to complete in this platform
mode you will also get an email
notification after the pipeline is
finished okay for me it's done so let us
additionally wait some time to reloading
updates the progress indicator and after
the pipeline is completed
you see 100% done signature in the top
right corner so if you have the pipeline
completed you may take a look at the
output the main output of the pipeline
is stored in the download pipeline
output files folder so in the left
folder you see here download pipeline
output files these are the main output
files so go in here for example we have
a PDF file PC plots so this is the
visualization we wanted to have so I
download this file and open it each dot
is associated with one sample and we
started our discussion from the fact
that all cell lines originated from the
patients with the same pathology and we
wanted to see whether all cell lines are
similar however here we see at least two
groups of samples we definitely see a
clear separation of samples into two
groups probably somebody will see
additional separation in two groups in
the left
or in the right parts at the same time
we know that there are multiple subtypes
of breast cancer and who may hypothesize
that this separation is related to the
subdivision into subtypes and the
authors of this study we are working
with the author of the study that
produced the data classified all the
samples into four classes into four
types of the breast cancer luminal
subtype basal subtype cloud in low
subtype and normal like subtype so in
fact we have information about clinical
subtype for each sample and probably it
would be interesting to see how subtypes
are located into in these plots well we
can describe the picture but a better
way to look at it is to generate the
picture in the same folder in the main
file folder we have an additional file
expression data
macht it is just the same file but for
which each sample is marked by a
subgroup is marked by subgroup so let us
repeat generating PCA PCA plot but
upload this file cell lines expression
days marked in order to get different
colors for dots associated with
different subtypes so the analysis is
just the same but the picture will
include information about the predefined
class so in order to do it we create one
more by plying just the same one we used
unsupervised analysis in this
unsupervised analysis we upload the file
but this time we upload the file
expression data marked
[Music]
we upload the file expression data
marked that's it so again the difference
is that just here we have predefined
classes for samples and we'll see how
these classes are located in planes and
all the same steps are the following is
a simple analysis so we upload the data
we upload the data and then just repeat
the steps we did continue part piecing
you draw for example with different with
default parameters and give a name to
the pipeline and run it okay maybe this
is a good time to see if everybody is
following along and if there's any
questions that we have I have this
especially the gene names with this or
the data needs to be in this particular
format of having samples versus did you
get that Redeemer Oh could you please
repeat the question because the order is
a bit worse than I want it to be yes I
understand the question is about
formatting the input file for the PCA
how do you have to organize your
transcripts and samples very much
perfect question
so here we have multiple options we can
first for the PCA for the principle
component analysis transport or gene IDs
are simply ignored so in this type of
the analysis we have features but
feature names are not essential then we
can arrange samples by columns and
features by rows or vice versa and all
we need let me show you I'll just show
you it on the screen I upload well any
file all we need here is to tell system
which goes by rows and we what
information goes by columns in our case
when samples are columns we said
transpose equal to yes and in the
opposite case we simply said transpose
equal to no and if we have additional
information about classes or groups or
something like that we simply add a line
marked by a keyword group here to here
the keyword is groups with a name of a
group so again here are two options are
possible what goes by rows what goes by
columns both options are possible okay
are there any other questions so
meanwhile I've got a question to you so
if we look at the previous PC what here
it is on my screen and remember that
there are four subtypes
what's your idea how these subtypes
would be located two on the left and two
on the right or something different so
can we make a prognosis looking at this
picture - just get feeling the hill can
you be the voice of the feeling and so
what does the voice of the feeling say
so frankly speaking I also have no
hypothesis looking at this figure but
anyway let's look at the correct answer
so hopefully the pipeline is completed
for you as well so please let me know if
I'm wrong for the next pipeline will
simply have a loop you will simply have
a look at new plots we have here and
what we see is that the luminal subtype
is very well separated from three other
subtypes again PC plot but these are the
subtypes are relatively close to each
other in the first plane principal
component one versus two we set number
of principal components to be drawn to
three that is why we also have planes
associated with principal components one
and three two and three and here in the
next plane you see that cloud and low
subtype is well also separated from
basal and normal like but basil and
normal like subtypes look similar anyway
it please pay your attention to the fact
that initially we knew nothing about the
subtypes
but this analysis provided us an
unsupervised but very clear very
definitely
raishin enter at least two groups but
this is a visual inspection and visual
inspection can hardly tell us what is a
normal well an acceptable a good number
of clusters of groups for a given set of
samples so here we see that at least two
but if we knew nothing about true
subclasses we could not set the number
of subclasses 2 3 4 5 so on based just
on our visual inspection so let us
create one more pipeline for the
unsupervised analysis of the data it's
just in the same section for performing
formal clustering in our case
hierarchical clustering of the samples
we have so again we go to the
unsupervised analysis section again we
upload the file expression data this
time we do not need marks we don't need
information about subtypes about classes
that's why we again upload the file cell
lines expression data so
again it may take some time we start
creating pipeline and this time we want
to perform clustering for example using
each class using hiragana clustering
model so each cost here it is here it is
here let me know if everybody's here as
here we'll set a bit different options
for example we'll set the expected
number of clusters to 4 if you like 5
more please keep 5 absolutely not a
problem let us change linkage type for
example towards d2 so it's more
important because linkage type is an
essential parameter of hierarchical
clustering so linkage type is changed to
for example words d2 definitely it's not
the only possible option and that's all
that's all again do transpose simply
tells which information goes by cones
and by rows that's it that's it so we
give any name for the pipeline and start
it great so while it's running let's
briefly discuss what is performed by
these pipeline so initially we know
nothing about the number of groups so
initially we look at our samples which
are here illustrated by dots in a plane
and associate one group with each
individual sample so initially in the
bottom-up approach of hierarchical
clustering
we have the number of clusters of
potential clusters of potential groups
equal to the number of samples then we
simply unite two samples which are the
closest into one group and treat these
samples as an inseparable well met a
sample acquires a sample so for us
currently it's one meta sample but not
two individual samples so it's one dot
instead of two dots and then we continue
the same process we look at two samples
of meta samples which are most close to
each other and unite them into one group
so at each step the number of groups is
reduced by one we continue the process
and we unite the closest pair of samples
into one groups but here well initially
we need to set distance between
individual samples and here we need to
define what is the distance between meta
samples between what is the distance for
the situation when at least one argument
is not a standard sample but a group of
samples well quite a sample
so this distance can be defined in two
very different ways minimal distance
between samples from the first group and
from the second group maximum distance
mean distance or more complex definition
so it is the question so it's the fact
determined by the linkage type how to
define the distance between these quasi
groups what formula is used so this
process goes on and on and on at each
step we add we reduce the number of
groups by one and finish this process by
one group that unites all the samples at
this visualization it's hard to
understand the logic it's hard to
understand how the process goes on but
there's once
more standard visualization for the
out of the hierarchical clustering
so-called dendrogram so let us have a
look at the progress of our pipeline
well let's inspect what's going on there
so the mine is done so please let me
know if yours is done as well so if it
is again if we want to inspect our
results visually we have a PDF file cell
lines expression data series each class
dot PDF and here you see the results
samples in our case breast cancer cell
lines go into the line below and
step-by-step these cell lines are united
in two groups the hate at which two sub
groups are united shares the measure of
dissimilarity between these two groups
for example if the if grouping is
performed at a low height then the
united groups are similar if we unite
two groups at high height it means that
groups are not similar at all so these
figure clearly states that we have two
well-defined clusters and potentially
both clusters can be further divided
into two subgroups but if you have a
look a close look at this figure you'll
see that these groups would just
coincide with the subtypes we have for
example one of our
subtypes normal-like subtype yeah normal
like subtype is located in the rectangle
you see marked as green so if we cut
this tree into two groups
we need to select the cut height at the
level of 300 400 we have two groups if
we cut the tree at a low height we get
four groups if we continue reducing the
cutoff height we get more groups but
please take a look what will be the next
separation if we reduce the height to
the level of approximately 200 here
you'll see that HCC 202 cell lion will
be identified as a separate cluster as a
separate outlier so just the same cell
line that was identified by the analysis
explained by Julia anyway four clusters
I seen really clearly in this figure and
there's no wonder that luminal subtype
here is subdivided into two classes as
indeed it includes two subtypes of the
second-level luminal a subtype and women
will be subtype we obtain this division
into clusters in an unsupervised manner
looking at all genes looking at all
genes after very single tree filtration
exclusion of jeans with concentrate low
expression level the question is can we
get more looking at lower number of
genes so we can we get more information
looking at much lower number of genes it
seems that we lose many information
limiting our focus on just a few genes
but at the same time if we analyze large
of genes the majority of genes the
majority of transcripts simply introduce
the noise so there are only some genes
related to the question of interest and
reducing the number of genes were
looking at can potentially improve
signal-to-noise ratio
indeed we'll lose some information but
still we can keep much information and
greatly reduce the level of noise for
example let us look what can be done
just in a similar analysis type if we
limit our attention on 15 genes out of
our initial set so let us create two
pipelines similar to the ones we just
created just the same types of the
analysis but limited to 15 genes again
we're in the unsupervised analysis
section so first for the PCA analysis we
upload the file cell Lyons 15 genes
marked in order to see the complete
figure cell lines 15 genes marked
here it is it's small there are only 15
genes not 7,000 so PC draw analysis you
see a draw analysis is the the first
pipeline we're going to create half the
second pipeline we're going to create in
a very similar way is pipeline for each
cluster in this case we upload non
marked file cell lines 15 genes cell and
15 genes and again perform job the same
steps we upload this small file we
upload this small file and create a
pipeline each class for example with 4
clusters again you can keep any other
number of clusters as it does not affect
it does not affect the dendrogram we get
and again linkage type the algorithm for
getting distance between coitus samples
set to worth d2 we save it and go on and
complete this pipeline each cluster
and run it
okay we'll soon have the results for
these pipelines but in any case if we
look at these tables will again see that
for these tables just a moment let me
show you for these tables the selected
genes are identified by their in symbol
IDs so information that's potentially
hardly interpretable as only few of us
remember the association of specific
genes with their own sample IDs so if we
wants to get more meaningful information
about genes gene names let us run the
third pipeline and then just check
generate the results just gather the
results the pipeline we're going to run
the next pipeline is associated with the
utility section we simply want to know
what are the genes were working with so
we upload our file cell lions 15 genes
the Lions 15 genes
and use annotation model that will look
at the database and add standard gene
symbol and [ __ ] categories to each gene
we have in our table so that's it
annotation for example with the default
categories okay okay so let me just
repeat all the steps the question is how
to restore how to restore gene symbols
and go-go categories heaven for example
in sample gene IDs well technically it
can be done simply by using the platform
by creating a pipeline at the utility
section so we upload a file with genes
for which we want to know these gene
symbols these annotations just the file
were working with and create a pipeline
with the annotation model it says that
for example gene on transcript IDs
located at column one in a table that
has a header we want to add information
including GU categories so that is very
simple pipeline
that's it
okay and let us look at the results let
us look at the results what we get which
pipelines are completed for you which
are not in any case what we have for
these 15 genes for these 15 genes we
have a much clearer separation of groups
on the PCA plane so is the figure you
get out of the PCA analysis and indeed
we see that going into lower number of
genes well into the subset of genes we
can call a gene signature we can have
clear a figure of what's going on and
just a moment
and if we see if we look at the results
of irrigator clustering you obtained
okay perfect
so if you download the results of the
hiragana clustering you'll see the
dendrogram I am having here with
additional marks so I just point your
attention to the fact that these 15
genes indeed give us clustering into
four clusters that perfectly coincides
with the division into four subtypes
number of genes with an increase of
signal-to-noise ratio or an analog of
this signal-to-noise ratio gives us the
result
perfectly concordant with what we're
dealing with so that you record your
clustering and finally we're waiting for
the results of the annotation which will
also give us gene symbols and all the
other data type but it is the result of
the unsupervised analysis it is the
result of the unsupervised analysis
definitely there are multiple other
methods for unsupervised analysis for
example for clustering well known method
is k-means there are other methods for
clustering that may produce results
different from the hierarchical
clustering and that may require
different input for example 40 means we
do not have a clear visualization with a
dendrogram and have two predefined K
number of clusters number of groups
[Music]
in advance but this initial analysis
linked with clinical data linked with
Vernon typic data gives us separation of
our samples into groups and we have
another task having the separation of
samples into groups how to identify the
group for new samples for example having
our data set as a learning set we
identified that breast cancer patients
can be divided divided into subgroups
and how to define how to understand
which what is the subgroup for a new
patient it's the question for the
supervised analysis so probably at this
point we may have a short break
well if you are a bit tired
and finally in our final part before a
short hand hands-on practice will
briefly describe discuss the analysis in
a supervised problem statement when we
initially have this division in the
subgroups that we could identify using
unsupervised analysis okay so as I
understand in about 15 minutes
okay so in this case we can simply try
to have a simple example which will show
you that indeed these methods of the
analysis can simply be used to analyze a
data set you know nothing about
initially so what I'm talking about is
the following in the set of files do you
have there's a subfolder hands-on
what is this set of data we have in this
file we took two additional projects
both dealing with breast cancer but in
one project the samples were human
samples just biopsy samples their biopsy
samples or tissues taken in frames of
surgeries and the other data set is
Centegra is data originated from a
patient arrives and graft project so
human breast cancer was implanted into
mice and then taken again out of the
non-human mice micro environment and
it's clear that micro environment in
human and in mice should be different
and disabled samples should also be
different so we took just the same 15
genes to make the analysis faster but
the samples here are intermixed so some
samples are associated with humans Sam
associated with mice
so could you divide this set into a
human set and my set
probably not named in each one but
telling which samples belong to the
first and which samples belong to the
second using the automatic modules we've
discussed so in order to understand that
this analysis is really simple
in spite of in spite of the fact that
the number of the amount of information
is relatively large while dozens of
samples and several genes so the task is
to separate these datasets into two
different really different subsets mice
and human derived samples this the task
clear
so as the heel is walking there behind
said he'll just let us know if everybody
is following if everybody has seen the
file it's in the original zipped folder
that you download it there is a file
fill hands on and the only file in the
folder hands on file with intermixed
file with intermixed datasets human
derived and mice do ok and people that
are just joining online you can also let
us know on chat if you are following
along or if you are having any issues in
the meantime I just want to mention also
Vladimir there is somebody requesting
clarification on the steps for the
annotation pipeline so if at some point
we can review that again that would help
sure sure so probably a good option is
to give several minutes to implement
these hands on task and then return to
the annotation pipeline
okay if you've started your pipelines
and just waiting for the results well
please let me know and we can briefly
discuss these annotation and then to go
through some additional topics very
briefly
[Music]
[Music]
okay so again regarding annotation here
currently we're talking about very
simple annotation about taking an
assembled gene or transcript IDs and add
an information which is simpler for
manual interpretation i mean gene
symbols so just standard gene names and
gene ontology terms cell localization
gene ontology functions and so on and in
order to perform this pipeline
definitely all we need is the set of
example gene or transcript identifiers
in our case these identifiers allocated
into in the first column of the table so
we simply upload this file we simply
upload this file but this one for
example and tell that we need to add
information for identifiers stored in
the first column of the table that the
table has a header so the first row is
not it is simply a header and we want to
include gene ontology data into the
output that is all that is all and the
output for this pipeline I hope you also
have an output for this pipeline
includes a table marked with out suffix
so it is just an initial table in the
week in the right gene symbols are added
so here for these assembled genes gene
symbols are added and here you see that
in our subset of 15 genes there is for
example a very well known epithelium
cell adhesion molecule he become is
present and then goo terms are
associated with each gene for example
for the case of this well-known hidden
molecule Rahzel domes include plasma
membrane as its adhesion lateral plasma
membrane integral component of membrane
and others so for for example DC and
prodding these Gautam's
include wound healing as a biological
process along with gene symbols here we
see food well a bit fuller description
full gene name for example collagen type
6 primer etc so it's a simple very
simple annotation limited to add in gene
symbols gene ontology annotation so if
you are ready with the hands-on test we
can discuss the results and then briefly
discuss just a couple of more topics
whatever there is also a question here
if you will after this hands-on work go
over a standard differential expression
pipeline with four annotation exactly
exactly
so again and asking Sahil is the voice
as the voice from there what are the
approaches you test it in order to
separate the data set into two subsets
and what results did you get any ideas
you're also welcome to write your ideas
on chat and we'll announce them here
okay so both options we discuss to the
principal component analysis and
hierarchical clustering analysis both of
them can solve the problem we have here
for example for example if we perform
here our kacal clustering for this file
well for example I'll show you the
result with two factors in an output
well we'll see what's happening and
principal component analysis potentially
can also call this task but the output
will be a bit longer to interpret so
initially we have groups completely
intermix okay the answer here from the
audience
somebody said PCA with two groups
exactly
so PC give two groups let me just take a
look okay for example as we are waiting
for the result I'll run this pipeline
and it's really fast
[Music]
so what we have for hierarchical
clustering as an output here we see two
well-defined groups and the answer for
this shot for this simple task is the
following all samples marked with odd
numbers belong to one group all the
samples marked with even numbers 256 60
etcetera belong to two groups so this
separation is just because indeed one
subset is human derived and the other
subset is mize derived and in human
derived samples all the samples belong
to the same subtype so that's why the
unification height is relatively low and
in the my stride subset in PDX subset
there were two types of breast cancer
and these two types are defined by these
clusters that can be obtained by cutting
the tree at the height of for example 30
so indeed again here occur clustering
gives us a clear separation and if we
look at the results of the principal
component analysis after we get it it's
it will take just
or seconds we'll also see these clear
separation for the hierarchical
clustering definitely we have not only
the plots but we have additional
information for example we have a file
with the suffix clusters only dot txt
and just a moment what is the content of
this file I'll open it in Excel to a
simpler view so for each sample this
file gives a cluster identifier we set
the number of clusters equal to two so
the cut off height was selected in such
a way that the result a number of
clusters is two if we've said the cut
off level two three four etc we'll have
the same number of clusters here and
looking at samples united in one cluster
is very simple we just look at samples
marked with the same cluster ID and in
the pc plane we indeed also have a
similar separation into two groups one
group the left and bottom and the other
group top right so it is the separation
so having groups heaven the groups we
can think about the next problems and
one of the problems is to find genes
that have different expression
in these subgroups we're dealing with so
first we need to we need to define we
need to analyze to understand what does
it mean a gene has different expressions
in the in to compared classes in to
compared subgroups first we may look at
mean expression levels the different
expression means that average expression
levels are also different but look at
the example features to the right of
this slide you definitely see no
differential expression in the upper
case and evident differential expression
in the lower case in that blue group of
samples expression level is evidently
much higher than in the red group of
patients at the same time the difference
between means in the upper and
antilochus is just the same one in log
to scale so two-fold difference in the
initial scale that is why fourth change
the difference between means can be used
as the only parameter as the only
characteristic of differential
expression we also need to consider
statistical significance of this
differential expression obtained using
one of the standard or non-standard
statistical tests in the simplest case
it is a student test or so called T
tests that compares the difference
between average levels of expression
levels compared to deviations compared
to variations inside expression levels
in each group more complex cases which
are
better for small sets of samples use
more complex statistical schemes for
example statistical schemes based on
negative binomial distributions are
popular technically in order to get the
set express genes if we want to use a
simple test for example t-test we can do
it even taking expression levels
provided by our previous pipeline one of
our previous pipelines as an input but
more complete as I told more complex
statistical approaches are preferable so
in order to use more complex statistical
approaches let me just show you the
pipeline design we can create this
pipeline together all we need is to
upload samples where it wants to compare
my case I'll use another set of links to
files that are already present in the
platform links cloud in low versus
normal like samples the above six
samples in this set are close in low
breast cancer cell line samples and
lower 5 samples are normal like samples
but in these case so in this case we
want to compare expression levels in
true route to want to find genes that
have higher expression in one group and
lower expression in the other group so
we need to specify which samples belong
to which group that potentially can be
more than two groups but let us limit
our consideration to two groups so for
example as I told in these case in
these case lure fire samples belong to
one group and above six samples belong
to the other group and if we initially
know the difference between which sample
belong to which group here we press
Continue as we have groups well submit
changes in groups and create a pipeline
similar to the ones we initially had as
here we again start with raw sequencing
data with first you data so I just
recreate the pipeline we had initially
but here at the end we wants to find the
set of differentially expressed genes of
differentially expressed genes it can be
performed if we want to use more complex
statistical models based on negative
binomial distribution for example by
well known H R or D SEC two modules so
technically technically that is all so
we give a name pipeline and run it
regardless of the module will we're
using regardless of the module we're
using what we get as an output what we
get as an output annotated output for
this pipelines is provided in the sub
folder output files then we can go
further into the differential expression
subfolder so the outputs have similar
meanings and I'll pay here attention to
the main information just a moment sorry
just a moment so let us take any
what in what information can be used
here so let me sorry just a moment just
a moment okay okay
so what information we have after the
differential expression analysis for
each gene or for each transcript we have
full change potential mainly log for
change the science shows in which group
the expression level is higher then we
have statistical significance of the
differential expression the probability
that we'll have the same or even higher
for change in the case when in reality
there's no difference in mean expression
levels adjusted p-value which is the
main parameter estimate that is examined
if we want to look at the set of really
differentially expressed genes and the
base level so the mean expression level
in both groups or the main expression
level in just one of the groups it
depends on the instrument by using so if
the standard output of n a 2 for the
analysis of differential expression so
we'll get just this similar we'll get
just a similar output for dc-to-dc HR
etc and what our first do you know what
is the reason for adjusting statistical
significance for adjusting p-value in
this case so why do we need to
additionally add some adjusted p-value
which is also denoted as a family false
discovery rate if they are proven to
value etc so the reason is the following
it
be explained by a very simple example
imagine that you have a coin you drop
this coin ten times and ten times it
fells with the same side up so it is
suspicious the probability that it's a
standard coin and it dropped ten times
all ten times the same side up the
probability is low but if we repeat this
experiment for several thousand times
we'll definitely have several coins with
this behavior it does not mean that
these coins are not normal it
potentially simply means that the number
of tests we were simultaneously writing
the number of points was too high and
what we see is associated not with
individual coins but with the number of
tests so this adjustment takes into
account the number of tests the number
of genes we're dealing with and in order
to select differentially expressed genes
in a standard sense so what are the
standard thresholds standardly a gene is
called differentially expressed if
adjusted p value to value FDR does not
exceed 0.05 that is 5% and standardly
has full change of at least two times so
log full change of at least one so
higher than 100 with n minus 1 these are
the thresholds that are not universal in
different types of the analysis must
treat thresholds can be used for example
0.01 one to stand for adjusted p-value
and more severe threshold for the full
change
additionally in many cases lower express
genes are simply eliminated from the
analysis as we initially discussed that
the error in quantification of
expression levels for these genes is
much higher but anyway the result of
this analysis is the table which further
allows you to select main players in the
field of differentially expressed genes
so the main parameters are full change
statistical significance mainly measured
in adjusted prevail your false discovery
rate as another name for the same and
additionally it's a good idea to exclude
genes with low expression after having
genes after having this analysis we may
think about further biological
interpretation we may try to think about
the following question is there any
pathway is there any pathway is there
any well experimental group of genes are
expressed by differentially expressed
genes can we say that in our experiment
genes associated with a particular
biological sense increase or decrease
their expression and there are multiple
approaches to try to give an answer to
this question of interest so the first
idea is very simple and it is utilized
for example by the well known delete
online service david service for gene
enrichment analysis let us simply take a
set of genes with the highest level of
differential expression with the lowest
adjusted p-values and highest for
changes and simply forget about these
additional parameters well let us simply
take these genes and let us try to
lies whether these top jeans well say
100 or 1000 genes are enriched by genes
belonging to a particular pathway what
does it mean gene this gene set is
enriched by genes belonging to a
particular pathway it means that if we
take random genes with a number equal to
the number of genes in our pathway the
probability of getting the same number
of genes belonging
buthe to the pathway and to power a set
of differential expressions is low so
for example in our set we have 50 genes
belonging to this pathway and in reality
if we take the same number of genes the
probability of having 50 or more genes
is low so that is the approach used for
example by diet as the first generation
gene enrichment tools the problem here
is the following we ignore too much
information with not too much
information associated with genes in the
results of differential expression
analysis for example we completely
forget we completely forget about the
level of differential expression for
example about full changes here losing
such a great amount of information leads
to poor example at the poor results of
the analysis the second level of these
instruments takes into account these
additional information about
differentially expressed genes for
example log fold changes and we have a
platform for example there's a module
based on our our script gauge
adopted for a simple use
with human experiments and the gives us
an opportunity to give a national
interpretation to give a natural
interpretation of the differential
expression analysis results so in order
to save time I'll just show you what we
get in the enrichment analysis for this
experiment first just a moment first for
each analyzed pathway we get a
statistical significance of enrichment
so we see which pathways are really
enriched by genes in our set of
differentially expressed genes sandal
parameter used is adjusted devalue that
in many cases denoted as Q value so here
we see that for example focal adhesion
get some signal pathway our Y
differentially expressed genes and if
we're looking at standards pathways for
example KEGG pathways we also have a
national visualization of differential
expression we have pathways we have
pathway in which players are colored and
the color code is based on the full
change level genes differentially
expressed in one direction for example
downregulated are marked in one color
and genes with the opposite regulation
are marked with another color so this
analysis is non-trivial from the
statistical point of view but it is
trivial from the technical point of view
using the platform so all we need to do
is to upload the file but here please
take into mind that for these type of
the analysis if we want to use the
complete information about full changes
we need to upload the hell table not
only differentially expressed genes but
the whole totality of genes in the
experiment as the method requires all
information as the background for its
statistical model and the output is just
what I'm showing you so technically this
unfree Ville analysis can be performed
simply in the case of Talbert by and for
platform in the utility section by using
the human gauged model unfortunately it
seems that the time is coming to its end
but you've got all the files for testing
it and I definitely will be happy to
answer your questions if you'll try to
test it and if you see that certain
parameters seem to be unclear so you
have a form here to present your
questions and we'll definitely try to
answer them so yeah as far as I see
problem where I'm out of time and we
will be happy to try to answer your
questions but also I you can let us know
I know that some people had to leave if
you don't have to leave we can just
finalize this one last pipeline and look
at the outputs if you would like to
there's a few more things to that
pipeline that could be shown but you you
can let us know I don't know so he'll if
you can okay so that somebody is asking
is it possible to save the file after
adapter cleaning RNA editing run okay
it's it's
simple question and I'll give a fast
answer to this question if we look at
the pipeline any pipe landing with these
modules we have final results in the
main download section and the main
download section but all intermediate
results are also well I am just looking
at the complete pipeline in my stack
just a moment example hopefully here it
is yeah
so all intermediate results are also
accessible in the folder job stem
profiles so for each job for example
tremor Matic BCR cleaning there are all
intermediate file saved and they're also
downloadable so all statistics all
intermediate files are accessible ok so
that answers that question so the
question about what the pipeline looks
like with gauge with it with the
enrichment analysis we we can finish
that pipeline and just look a little bit
more in detail into the outputs of the
pathways if everybody has time so if you
have time let's just continue we'll take
just a few more minutes
Vladimir do you want to just demonstrate
the pipeline with gauge and okay just
try to find files we have okay it's
absolute not a problem so again let us
briefly take first a look at the input
for this pipeline the gauge may deals
only with two types of gene identifiers
gene symbols and
and tres IDs so insane bill identifies
should be transferred to something like
that it can be done simply with the
annotation section probably it will
require some time to annotate thousands
of genes but in any case it's not a
problem so what is the mood for the
gauge pipeline it is just the output of
the differential expression analysis
pipeline so we have IDs we have the
parameters that characterize the rate of
differential expression the gauge takes
one parameter as an input standardly
it's log to full change and additionally
as I said gauge deals with gene symbols
or interest IDs so we added gene symbols
using sample IDs that were initially
present in the output so is the input
the minimal input and in fact the
complete input that is used contains two
columns gene identifiers given by gene
symbols or interest IDs and rates of
differential expression given for
example with log two for changes that is
the input and in order to generate this
pipeline we have to go to the utilities
section upload this file for the deseg
two out this is a file district full
output annotated annotated here means
that we just edit gene symbols from the
HR a simple file is one below there we
have just a slightly different
of columns so I download I upload this
file to the system and let us take a
look at options we need to specify for
this model the options are quite simple
and comments are accessible if we we
point at the I section we have
explanations in our table let me show it
once again we have the header so corn
headers are present corn with gene IDs
where gene IDs are gene symbol or entrez
ID in our case is the second one and let
us remember that full change is
allocated in the fourth column so gene
identifier is allocated in the second
column second column sorry bring
characteristics of the french expression
for example full changes are located in
to the fourth column there are two types
of the analysis parametric or
nonparametric both are applicable to
fall changes if we use statistical
significance cout value for example as a
matter of differential expression
nonparametric statistical approach is
preferable then we select the set of
genes the set of pathways we are going
to look at for example standards get met
sig is the set of KEGG pathways related
to metastatic cakes metastatic and
signaling pathways finally we set a
direction of differential expression
that is taken into account combined
means that we combine up and down
regulated genes
separate means that we separately annal
analyze downregulated genes and
upregulated genes and down and up means
that we limit our analysis only to down
or up regulated genes now the final
threshold is simply for drawing will
draw the best ways with enrichment
significance that does not exceed
threshold of 10% so false discovery rate
below 10% and that is all so that is all
we need for this pipeline that is all we
need for this pipeline it will take some
time to be completed as the input here
as I said completes the complete set of
genes here we left even unexpressed in
so 60,000 but it won't take too long
so probably if you have some additional
questions we'll see the output just
today ok so additional questions one is
can you draw a curve of the gene set
enrichment analysis as an output from
this gauge but so here I need to
understand what the meaning by the curve
associated with gene and Reena I can I
have this question from Andy B I don't
know if you're in the audience maybe you
can ask directly yes so if you just
provide a comment what curve do you mean
I'll give you an answer so currently we
have all these pathways cake pathways
Stanley
their allies get pathways with color
codes of differential expression and the
text tables so currently additional
curves are included but in the majority
of cases it's not a problem in any way
for multiple modules including this one
we output not only the results of the
processing but we also output our
scripts that are used in our inside the
platform to provide the analysis results
so what we also have is an R script that
performs everything from taking initial
data to producing the plots so if any
additional information is required this
R scripts can be used as a base and it
can be slightly edited for example by
user if a user knows bases of coding to
get any additional information available
inside and inside this type of the
analysis another in what situations do
you supervise and in what situation to
use unsupervised okay thank you very
much for this question the difference is
in problem statements so these methods
provide answers to completely different
questions in the first case we know
nothing about separation of our samples
if we analyze samples in the subgroups
so we just have a set of samples and the
task is to understand whether this group
of samples can be subdivided into any
well more or less natural subgroups we
do not know this division but in this
type of problem statement
we try to find this division so in any
case unsupervised analysis means that we
know that we have no additional
information about these samples in the
supervised analysis we initially have
information about samples for example
about classes of samples about subgroups
of sample and the question is not to
divide the group of samples into new
subgroups we already know the subgroups
but the question is the following how
can we construct 2yoon a classifier
function that will take new samples as
an input and attribute these new samples
to one of the groups we initially had so
we had patients we already divided them
somehow into subgroups and then for new
patients we wants to attribute these new
patients to one of the groups we
initially had this is the problem for
the supervised analysis type okay with
order could you please repeat your
question
okay sorry so what about replicates okay
near analyze biological areas well it
depends again it depends on the problem
we're dealing with in our case it
depends on the experiment you're working
with I won't give you the universal
answer here but in a way in many
analysis biological replicates can be
just be grouped into one subgroup a
group of samples in the analysis so we
can account this information that a set
of what a number of samples are simply
biological replicates by United these
samples enter subgroup but again a lot
depends on the design of the experiment
of the number of major groups we have
number of different conditions
we have we definitely should understand
that there are independent samples there
are biological replicates for some well
conditions for some effects and moreover
in multiple experiment designs there are
technical experiment technical
replicates we definitely should take
this into account and do not treat
technical replicates similarly to
treating independent samples but
unfortunately I don't know the universal
answer here it depends again on the
macro design of the experiment okay we
have enough yeah can the platform
perform whole exome analysis
just a moment try to give an answer
usually yeah it depends on the goal of
the analysis the answer is yes for the
many types of the health exam analysis
for example for the identification of
snps of copy number variation there's a
section that performs this job currently
we're trying to update this section to
add some modern approaches but the
formal answer to this question is yes
there's such a section what was that I
did not hear that
are their genomes non-human genomes so
basically we have several model
organisms here so you see the list
starting from Earth adoptions finishing
with well relatively rare types of
genomes it's not complete these are just
the genomes we had to work with but
adding a new genome is a simple
relatively simple task so if there's a
project or there's a user who needs to
deal with another standard genome
is genome can be added to the system and
edits to all these forms currently I see
that the guiche pipeline is completed so
as we discussed the output here is
gathered in one zip archive just in
order to avoid that multiple files and
the type of the market the type of files
here is the one we discussed we have a
simple set of pathways with enrichment
statistical significance associated with
each pathway and visualization for
enriched pathways okay so just to
summarize I know that people have to
leave but just to summarize we were able
to go through several sections
next-generation sequencing data
pre-processing including trimming
technical sequences and removing PCR
duplicates RNA seek based quantification
of expression levels so we looked at
standard mapping pipelines we did touch
on novel isoforms not in detail as we
hope to but we got through a lot of it
we also looked at gene set enrichment
analysis and this is just the output
here you can see that genes are
annotated with gene ontology and gene
descriptions as well as you can get all
the way to pathway and wait and see
which genes within the pathways are
under its plaster over expressed as well
as we looked at some of the machine
learning methods analyzing expression
data we looked at unsupervised methods
like PCA and clustering techniques and
then we looked at how to build a
supervised analysis using such methods
as SVM and so I get to mention the data
that we used we use data from two
publications
this whole line based modeling of
precision technology answer a project
that is available on our educational
site as well as whole transcriptome
profiling of pdx models as a tool to
identify both tumor and stromal specific
biomarkers and you can find the link to
this publication as well and it's also a
project that is available on our
educational site that you can play
around with and finally thank you for
dr. glen america ladunka
who is the chief scientist at the tower
by informatics Research Center and Julia
fell off
who is the PhD student that uses the
platform in some of our research
projects and again special thank you to
dr. Judy Iqbal from UNM see I have to
organize the room and brought a lot of
the people to the workshop and we will
be staying in touch by email if you want
to email us to heal myself or schedule a
time we plan to be there again and
organizing another workshop if you are
not able to attend or if somebody that
you think should attend a workshop like
this please let them know on the 20th we
will have another workshop at UNL and in
Lincoln asks a heal about that workshop
it will cover most of the same steps
that we did today but we will also touch
on some new things coming Thank You Leah